الحياة الطويلة هي نعمة وأحياناً
نقمة، لا يمكنك إيقاف الساعة التي
يتقدم بها جسمك في السن، يقول الدكتور كينيث كونسيليا
من كليفلاند كلينك إنه مع مرور السنين، فإن
الجسم المتغير يسمح بالمزيد من
المشاكل الصحية ولكن هناك
طرق صحية للشيخوخة  نصيحته الأولى: مارس
التمارين الرياضية يوميًا، والتزم بالنشاط كل
يوم ولكن اختر القيام بشيء تستمتع به.
الالتزامات بممارسة الرياضة أو الوعود التي قطعتها على
نفسك تصبح عادة فقط إذا كان هذا
شيئًا ستفعله
وستكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك
ستحب
تناول نظام غذائي صحي يحتوي على الكثير من
الفواكه والخضروات والحد من
الأطعمة المعالجة بالكحول واللحوم الحمراء، وهو أمر أساسي، كما تقول كونسيليا،
إنه من المهم أيضًا
مواصلة تعلم قراءة الكتب وتعلم
أشياء جديدة وتعلم العزف على آلة موسيقية
والغناء وتعلم لغة جديدة
وتعلم  هواية جديدة، هذه الأشياء كلها
تمارين رائعة لعقلك، ويمكن أن
تساعد أيضًا في البقاء اجتماعيًا، دفعة أخرى لعقلك،
أخيرًا، هل تستطيع سيليا
التركيز على الحصول على تلك الأشياء Z والتأكد من
أننا لا نشاهد التلفزيون أثناء
نومنا أو  أننا نحاول
الحصول على ما لا يقل عن ست إلى سبع ساعات من
النوم الجيد ليلاً
دون إزعاج، وهذا مهم جدًا لصحة
دماغك
ولفسيولوجيتك العامة
من أجل الصحة، أنا ماندي جايثر